well on this christmas day catholic
charities offered a christmas meal to
hundreds
as 8 news now reporter kate houston
tells us it's bringing hope and comfort
to those who need it most nearly 1 000
men and women will be served a christmas
meal today
catholic charities says that the need
this year is unlike any other
today staff is serving the homeless and
those on the brink of homelessness
their plates were filled with prime rib
vegetables and cake
catholic charities says this may be the
first nice meal they've had all year
due to the pandemic deacon tom roberts
says this year has been unique and
challenging
while the need in the community has
always been there he says
it feels different there's a bit more
desperation
a bit more anxiety a bit more tension
this year because so many people have
never been in this situation before
find themselves in these difficult
circumstances people like keith zorros
who's been homeless for a few months
i've been looking for work for months
you know
no nobody's hiring and it's very hard
to find a way back home
zoros tells me despite the challenges
he's facing
he's grateful for what he has i am
blessed
to have food on my plate because there
are brothers and sisters out there that
have no food on their plate
that don't come into these
establishments and
actually acquiesce to being given
gifts this is the 55th year catholic
charities has served a christmas meal to
the community
while there were no volunteers this year
staff was on hand to make sure everyone
followed health and safety guidelines
kate houston 8 news now and catholic
charities developed a special holiday
menu for today and
it was all free